hello everyone and welcome back to the
things today I'll be talking about one
of our favorite young stars who is quick
to take over the YouTube and television
space with her bubbly personality and
awesome dance moves now I know that Joe
Joe's got some amazing and very loyal
fans who know pretty much everything
about it but today I'm gonna be taking
you through some cameos that I bet you
never even noticed be sure to keep on
watching until the end because if you're
already a Joe Joe fan you are going to
love her even more and if not will then
get your boat ready because you will be
now I'll be looking for older ReelSEO or
inators in the comments section below so
be loud be proud bring that energy and
let me know which Joe Joe cameo is your
favorite what better way to start a
video about Joe Joe than wear her big
on-screen debut began lifetimes hit
series Abby Lee's ultimate dance
competition this show revolves a group
of 12 boys and girls and all of them
amazing dancers while all these dancers
brought a little piece of their adorable
personalities to the show it was missing
a little something that Joe Joe
definitely brought into season two now I
know it doesn't come to you guys as much
of a surprise that Joe Joe is on the
show however it is definitely worth
noting for her first showcase of her
talent energy and sass on screen Joe Joe
is a top five finalists in the
television series this is super
impressive since she was also one of the
youngest members to make it into that
season of the show I feel like I'm the
best dancer here and I think it's tiny
everyone else you realize it check out
some of our favorite joe joe moments on
Abby's ultimate dance competition when
she was only 12 Joe Joe had already
began promoting herself and her brand on
shows like Good Day LA and good day New
York perhaps one of her most impressive
interviews wasn't she made it onto the
UK show this morning with TV show host
Eamonn Holmes and Ruth Langsford in the
interview Joe Joe talks about she's just
naturally such an energetic person and
how she stays true to herself no matter
what people say about her since Joe Joe
was pursuing all her dreams of acting
singing and dancing she didn't exactly
experience bullying firsthand since she
was home-schooled she did however
experience some severe cyber bullying
either way all kinds of bullying is just
absolutely horrible so she definitely
had a few words to say on the matter
she mentioned how it is horrible that
people can actually say some rude things
about
one who they don't even really know she
claims that she wants to end bullying
whether cyber or IRL and make people
feel good about themselves no matter
what others say
see you inator or not you have to admit
that she makes a great point and we can
totally stand a cutie who stands up for
others throughout the rest of the video
she emphasizes that you need to surround
yourself with people who love you and
focus on just the positive she also
referenced how people our age are always
trying to act older than they are and
that they should more often focus on
being happy and having fun rather than
what others think of them I'm a
breakfast that is some awesome and
mature advice for someone who's only 15
years old
for this next cameo man out to take us
back to Joe Josie after her Dance Moms
era some of you might already know that
Jojo is friends with Maddie B who is
another YouTube sensation
Maddie B started his career back in 2010
when he was only 7 years old
he's known for posting remixes and his
own versions of some pretty popular pop
music and even including Jojo and some
of them the two are not closer than ever
but they originally met thanks to her
time with the Abby Lee dance company
Maddie B originally released the song
turn up the track in 2015 where he
starred dojo Nia and Kalani with Jojo
playing the love interest the video
turned out to be really sweet but the
story behind it not so much on the Dance
Moms season 5 episode wild wild west
coast part 2 we see Abby take all the
girls including Jojo to LA to audition
for Maddie's video now the main role
initially went to Mackenzie Ziegler
until Abby kind of pulled the plug on
the entire project
now since Abby was Mackenzie Maddie and
Kendall's manager at the time they were
forced to drop the project leaving only
Nia Kalani and Jojo to play in the video
now I definitely wonder what it would be
like if the girls did star in the video
and Mackenzie got her singing and lead
role the girls weren't too pumped about
this decision and I definitely still
wonder when Mackenzie would have been
like as the lead and singer in the video
however this made for a great cameo for
Jojo and a long-lasting friendship
between her and Maddie
besides Mackenzie is now killing it all
by herself and doesn't look like she
needs any help doing it not only has
Jojo dominated almost everything she's
ever tried it looks like she's been
slaying performances as back as when she
was just 2 years old back in 2015 Jojo
posted a compilation video of some of
her earliest performances to say they
were adore
is an absolute understatement bleach is
just sinking into that kid's brain the
video starts off with a sassy
performance by two-year-old Jojo showing
everybody that she was destined to make
it into the entertainment industry this
is one of those moments where you
definitely need to see it to believe it
so check out these snippets of baby Jojo
slaying the competition I don't know
about you but I can't wait to follow
JoJo's adventure and see what the future
has in store for this young star and
that is the end of our video guys I hope
you had fun and maybe even discovered
something new too if you already know
everything there is to know about Jojo
and are a diehard c18 er then how about
you help me oh and let me know in the
comments section below which Jojo cameo
is your favorite also let me know what
you think on her ponytail should she
lose the ponytail for 2019 or is it too
iconic to leave us anytime soon
I am definitely curious for your answer
on that one so be sure to let me know
and I'll see you guys in our next video
ciao
[Music]